animators love to slip their own little
jokes into the backgrounds of their
movies but the folks at Pixar I've taken
things to a new level adding tons of
hidden references to their own past and
future films into each of their movies
here's a look at the best of the best
Toy Story stories would he makes a
rousing speech in front of a bookshelf
and Toy Story if you examine the titles
of the books on the Shelf very closely
you'll spot a few familiar titles The
Adventures of Andre and Wally B tin toy
and knick-knack are all the titles of
short films that Pixar produced prior to
Toy Story don't overlook that carpet
there's a tense scene in Toy Story where
Buzz desperately tries to find an escape
route out of SIDS house lest you join
SIDS collection of misfit toys but what
makes it extra terrifying to those with
an eagle eye is the fact that SIDS
carpet is the same design as what's in
the Overlook Hotel from the 1980
thriller of The Shining The Lion King is
everywhere you'll have to squint to see
it but in a bug's life if you look very
closely during the scene of flick
soaking in the ambience of bug City
you'll see just how far the phenomenon
of the lion Kings Broadway adaptation
has traveled missus potato heads reading
material
when mr. Potato Head makes his
appearance in Toy Story 2 he pretty much
steals the show and mrs. Potato Head
agrees when she realizes that she's
found her missing earring she
immediately throws it down the book
she's been reading a storybook of a
bug's life a Nemo preview there are
Easter eggs and then there are next
level Easter eggs you know the bit of
Monsters Inc word boo hands Sully her
stuff Nemo well Finding Nemo didn't come
out until two years after Monsters Inc
it's all part of Pixar's master plan an
incredible cameo Pixar also snuck a
sneak peek of a future film into Finding
Nemo itself if you look closely at the
bit where the kid and the dentist's
office is scared senseless by the sounds
of Nemo's escape attempt you'll see that
he's reading a mr. incredible comic book
a full year and a half before the
Incredibles hit theaters Rex is an
extinct of all the things you'd expect a
survivor plant self-induced ecological
disaster in wall-e you'd wouldn't
predict that one of Andy's toys from Toy
Story would be on that list of items let
alone the one that's been extinct for
millions of years nonetheless when we're
giving a look into wall-e sanctuary and
see all the junk contained within its
walls
there's Rex's toothy grin smiling back
at you
postcard from the frederickson's as we
know from the opening credits have up
Carl and Ellie Fredrickson traveled
quite a bit in their youth in the
process they've apparently made a few
friendships that we've yet to see
explored if you take a very close look
at the bulletin board in Andy's room in
Toy Story 3 you'll see that the
Frederick's end sent Andy a postcard
that's considerate of them monster in
the woodwork when Princess Merida takes
it upon ourselves to stroll through the
forest she finds herself at the house of
a witch Merida watches in awe as a magic
broom moves around the room on its own
power but what's more fascinating is the
path it takes passed a law which has
Sully from monsters inc carved into it a
1:13 marks the spot you may already be
aware of how a113 has a tendency to show
up in just about every film produced by
Pixar it's shown up on a license plate
in Toy Story a train in cars on a tag
attached to get the rats a year in
ratatouille and in many many more places
so what is a 1:13 why not ask the man
himself Pixar's chief creative officer
John Lasseter a113 was the animation
classroom at California Institute of the
Arts in the character animation program
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos at
the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which Pixar
Easter Egg you liked the best
[Music]